في مكه المكرمه بدات اعمال التشجير في
ساحات ومرافق المسجد الحرام ضمن مبادره
اني اطلقت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين المبادره
تهدف الى تحسين البيئه العامه بالمسجد
الحرام وساحات التابعه له باستغلال
المساحات الخاليه والممرات وتحويلها اجزاء
منها الى احواض زراعيه كما تادف هذه
المبادره الى استغلال مياه الوضوء
ومعالجتها وتدويرها والاستفاده منها في
رعيه تلك المسطحات والهجره
من الحرم المكي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
سلطان السلمي حدثنا اكثر ااا بعد الترحيب
بك طبعا سلطان حدثنا اكثر عن هذه المبادره
وكيف يتم العمل على تنفيذه
اهلا بك خالد واهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه بالفعل بدات الرئاسه العامه
للشؤون الحرمين برفقه عدد من القطاعات
الحكوميه المهتمه بقطاع الزراعه بعامل
التسجيل وزراعه بعض النباتات في حول
الساحات الحرم المكي والاماء والمواقع
المفتوحه ضمن النطاق الحرم اريد ان يلقيكم
او نلقي نظره على بعض من هذه المبادره
والعمل على التسجيل وزراعه النباتات في
الساحات تعتبر الشماليه اللي هي الحرم
المكي وهي جزء من هذه المبادره والمشروع
من خلال وضع هذه النباتات في اماكن مرتفعه
بعيده عن متناول الايدي وذلك لاهداف عديده
منها لتعزيز جوده الهواء وكذلك لراحه
المعتمرين والمصلين وزوار المسجد الحرام
من خلف هذه وضع هذه الشجيرات وهذه
النباتات التي تم اختيارها وفق ضوابط
محدده من ضمنها نتحدث على بعض هذه الضوابط
المهمه التي
او نتحدث بدايه عن المساحات ونتحدث عن
7344 متر مربع من المساحات الخاليه بواقع
تحدث على 25 موقع نتحدث على مواقع
المقاربه لاسلام الكهربائيه والاسقف
العاليه وكذلك من الاستفاده منها من خلال
النشر الظل وكذلك اضافه زياده الاكسجين في
مساحات المفتوحه او شبه مغلقه في الحرم
هنالك جهات عديده او لجنه شكلت لهذه العام
او هذا المشروع تحدث عن الرئاسه العامه
لشؤون الحرمين وايضا المركز الوطني لتنميه
الغطاء النباتي وكذلك معهد ابحاث الحج
والعمره بجامعه ام القرى هنالك ضوابط
محدده ان من خلال استبعاد استقطاع اي
مساحات من المصليات او ما يؤثر على مسارات
حركه الحشود لذلك المشاهده في اماكن
مرتفعه ايضا لا تكون هذه النباتات لها اي
جذور عميقه وبالتالي يعني تؤثر بشكل او
باخر على البنيه التحتيه للمسجد الحرام
بسبب وجود تمديدات ومساله الخدمات ايضا
الا تكون هذه النباتات هي جاذبه الحشرات
او حتى الافات وبالتالي لا تؤثر على صحه
قاصدي المسجد الحرام اليوم هذه المبادره
تسعى في جوانب عديده منها كبيره جدا من
خلال العمل على هذه المبادره من ضمنها
تعزيز الغطاء النباتي لما له اثر ايجابي
في تحسين الجانب البيئي الذي ينعكس ايجابا
بطبيعه الحال على زوار المسجد الحرام هذه
هي المرحله الاولى سوف تشهد المواقع
مختلفه ومناطق مختلفه من المسجد الحرام
مثل هذه الاشكال من خلال استغلال كافه
المساحات الخاليه في المسجد الساحات
ومقابل الابواب والسلامه الكهربائيه وكذلك
الاسقف المعلقه نعم خالد
من الحرم المكي الشريف